[Music]
foreign so what would happen if all of
the power in our country went out at the
exact same time now this is the question
posed in Dennis Quaid's new documentary
called grid uh down power up and spoiler
alert uh things would not go that well
take a look
[Music]
virtually every study you'll see has an
anarchistic component that leads to
writing it is almost inevitable
imagine what will happen if there's no
food no power and no money and no
Transportation only people with guns and
the boldness to go and take what they
need to survive will live
it could literally end civilization as
we know it
Cyber attack
and EMP even a massive solar flare
they're all capable of exposing our
power grid as America's Achilles heel
all right joining us now Dennis Quaid
along with the producer of the film
David Tyson is with us thank you both
I am a fan of yours what's amazing about
you you came here you could be the
greatest father of the year in The
Parent Trap and be the biggest jackass
father and you know I can only imagine I
mean that shows great acting ability uh
that's what a range that that's a that's
a range that's a lot of range
um okay what interested you in this you
know we hear about Electro go ahead yeah
well there's something I'd I'd read
about it and chilled me uh quite a few
years ago and then uh David Tice who had
worked with before uh came to me about
something that concerned him too to make
this documentary on our electrical grid
to make people aware of how vulnerable
it is you know we've only been uh before
1920 we all lived in the dark and I
guess we were quite used to it but if it
were happened to a day to like a solar
flare event or uh an attack on uh our
substations the them going out we have
blackouts which we all know and have
lived through but it could take down the
entire at an EMP event could take down
the entire grid of the United States and
within 30 days we'd be back in the Stone
Age Again
walk through where this this documentary
will take us if it was an EMP event
electromagnetic pulse attack which I
think I'm hoping and praying and
assuming that our government is
preparing for uh but that would knock
out all the power in this country that's
a frightening scenario
yeah it really is there's three grids in
this country uh the eastern western and
the Texas Texas has its own grid and
it's they're quite vulnerable and it
would not take much and uh there's a
carriaging event with a solar flare
which in 1859 knocked out all of the
telegraph lines which was about the only
kind of electrical thing we had back
then in Europe and the United States and
uh you know this means for all the
refrigeration would go out just like
that all of uh uh Power stations we
wouldn't be uh able to have access to
food or communication and you know from
that chaos is going to erupt and it's
something we're very vulnerable with at
and there's something an easy fix to it
that uh we can do now it almost reminds
me of the Book of Eli with Denzel
Washington
um that kind of scenario where it just
you know whoever's left is it's just
total Anarchy uh David what got you
interested in this project and and why
was Dennis the perfect fit for you
well I got interested in this project
because I realized I was a nasty
grandfather when I was making a film
realized my grandkids were four three
two one flaska Houston we have a problem
we have a problem if we don't fix this
grid because my grandkids need to live a
long life and frankly a solar flare
there's a 12 probability every decade
that a significant solar flare could
essentially take out our grid so I've
been worried about this for a long time
and as far as Dennis I mean we know
everybody loves Dennis from from The
Parent Trap to the rookie you know he is
incredibly intelligent and you know
gifted with his uh knowledge of the
system and capitalism and and he
recognizes that we have a problem but he
believes in the American Spirit where we
can fix this yeah you know I'm like a
mini prepper I've got two huge
generators in part so I could broadcast
if God forbid you know such a thing
happens
um I wonder even if they would work and
I have you know thousands of of gallons
of propane underground for that reason
uh but when you think about it I don't
think most people are prepared you know
don't even have enough food dentists to
last a week never right you know and
what happens to the food supply what
happens to to pretty much every aspect
of our lives every aspect of Our Lives
that we just take for granted every day
is we're going to have to deal with it
another way and it won't be good and
there's there's a way to fix this this
is you know something that our
government could do that's definitely a
a nonpartisan issue that's for sure to
protect our substations of sort of like
a in a way that surge protectors we have
them on our televisions we have them for
Honor uh for our computers we could
install the these in our substations
that would protect us from from of if
event and event like this happened I'm
glad both of you did this because I do
believe this is a real threat and I
think you're right they need contingency
plans that they don't have them up to
date ready to go at a moment's notice uh
this country could be vulnerable to
attacks that we never dreamed of uh
where can people see this uh documentary
real quick uh David
okay so they can see the movie right now
on salemnow.com uh in in about two or
three weeks it's going to be available
on Amazon and also on YouTube
okay thank you both David thank you
thank you hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else